PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: YOU ARE SECOND
THOUGH.
YOU AND DAN.
JOINING US NOW FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE I ASSUME THE
WHITE HOUSE IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US.
>> HI, SEAN.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED AT
LENGTH IN AN INTERVIEW ABOUT
A LOT OF ISSUES.
LET ME START WITH THIS ISSUE
OF THE UKRAINE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE
FOLLOWING THE TOP OF THE
SHOW OR JOHN SOLOMON'S NEW
REPORT OR THAT BOTH
CATHERINE HERRIDGE AND SARA
CARTER ARE REPORTING TONIGHT
WE NOW HAVE TEXT MESSAGES
FROM PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE, NEVER BEFORE SEEN.
DISCUSSING RECRUITING WHITE
HOUSE SOURCES TO SPY ON YOU.
TAKE IT IN ANY ORDER YOU
WOULD LIKE.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLE WHEN YOU HEAR IT.
THESE ARE GREAT REPORTERS,
ALL THREE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THEM ON
YOUR TRAIL THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT SHOULD
BE GETTING PULITZERS NOT THE
ONES THAT GOT THE PULITZERS
THAT GOT EVERYTHING WRONG.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THEM, THEY
GOT EVERYTHING WRONG.
GO BACK AND READ SOME OF
THEIR EARLY AND MID
ARTICLES.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A CLUE WHAT
WAS GOING ON AND THEY WIN
PULITZER PRIZES.
THESE ARE THE ONES THAT
SHOULD BE WINNING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE BIG STUFF AND
SOUNDS VERY INTERESTING WITH
UKRAINE.
I JUST SPOKE TO THE NEW
PRESIDENT A LITTLE WHILE
AGO, TWO DAYS AGO AND
CONGRATULATED HIM ON AN
INCREDIBLE RACE.
INCREDIBLE RUN.
A BIG SURPRISE VICTORY.
75% OF THE VOTE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE BIG, BIG
STUFF.
I'M NOT SURPRISED.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT,
UKRAINE IS OFFERING THIS
EVIDENCE TO THE UNITED
STATES WOULD YOU LIKE THE
UNITED STATES WITH ALL THIS
TALK ABOUT COLLUSION.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY
INCLUDED ON BEHALF OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
IN 2016.
DOES AMERICA NEED TO SEE
THAT INFORMATION IN SPITE OF
ALL OF THE ATTACKS AGAINST
YOU ON COLLUSION?
>> WELL, I THINK WE DO.
AND, FRANKLY, WE HAVE A
GREAT NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO HAS DONE AN UNBELIEVABLE
JOB IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
HE IS VERY SMART AND TOUGH
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY DEFER
TO HIM.
I WOULD IMAGINE HE WOULD
WANT TO SEE THIS.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS
WHOLE CONCEPT OF UKRAINE
THEY HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IT ACTUALLY FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU KNOW THAT AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY DEFER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND WE'LL SEE WHAT HE SAYS
ABOUT IT.
HE CALLS THEM STRAIGHT.
THAT'S ONE THING I CAN TELL
YOU.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, OUR
OWN CATHERINE HERRIDGE,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER SARA
CARTER.
BIG BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
SENATE REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN
SUBMITTED A LETTER THURSDAY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
WE HAVE NEW TEXTS FROM
NOVEMBER OF 2016 FROM STRZOK
AND PAGE SHOWING THE PAIR
HAD DISCUSSED ATTEMPTS TO
RECRUIT SOURCES FROM WITHIN
YOUR WHITE HOUSE TO SPY ON
YOUR ADMINISTRATION AND
REVEAL THAT THEY HAVE ONE
PARTICULAR CONTACT WITHIN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
OF STAFF WHOSE WIFE WAS
WORKING AS AN ANALYST FOR
STRZOK OR THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY'S
PRIVATE SERVER.
HAVE YOU HEARD THIS REPORT
TONIGHT, SIR?
>> I JUST HEARD IT A LITTLE
WHILE AGO.
FRANKLY, IT'S VERY
DISCONCERTING, IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING,
THEY WERE THE SAME TWO, THE
TWO LOVERS THAT DECIDED TO
USE THE FBI SERVER INSTEAD
OF THEIR PRIVATE SO THEY
DIDN'T GET CAUGHT THESE TWO
WERE BEAUTY.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEY WERE GOING HOG WILD TO
FIND SOMETHING ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WASN'T THERE.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA EXCEPT THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TOUGHER ON RUSSIA THAN
ANY ADMINISTRATION IN 50
YEARS.
A LOT TOUGHER THAN OBAMA
THESE WERE THE TWO THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE INSURANCE
POLICY JUST IN CASE HILLARY
LOSES.
IF SHE LOSES WE HAVE GOT AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
WELL, THAT WAS THE INSURANCE
POLICY.
NOW SHE LOST AND NOW THEY
ARE TRYING TO INFILTRATE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REALLY
IT'S A COUP.
IT'S SPYING.
COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER
A LONG TIME AGO, VERY EARLY
ON I USED THE WORD WIRETAP
AND I PUT IT IN QUOTES,
MEANING SURVEILLANCE,
SPYING, YOU CAN SORT OF SAY
WHATEVER IF YOU WANT.
THAT WAS A LONG TIME AGO,
AND I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT A BLOW UP
LIKE YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN.
NOW I UNDERSTAND WHY.
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN I SAID THAT
JUST ON A LITTLE BIT OF A
HUNCH AND A LITTLE BIT OF
WISDOM, MAYBE.
THEY -- IT BLEW UP.
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT MAYBE I
WAS WISE TO THEM OR THEY
WERE CAUGHT.
AND THAT'S WHY.
BECAUSE, IF THEY WEREN'T
DOING ANYTHING WRONG.
IT WOULD HAVE JUST GOTTEN
BY.
NOBODY WOULD HAVE CARED
ABOUT IT.
IT WAS PRETTY INSIGNIFICANT.
I THOUGHT, WHEN I SAID IT,
AND THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
SO YOU SEE NOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO INFILTRATE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS LONG AFTER THE
ELECTION.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
AND, AGAIN, HOPEFULLY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL DO
WHAT'S RIGHT AND I REALLY
BELIEVE HE WILL.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACTUALLY
USED THE WORD "SPYING" ON
YOUR CAMPAIGN.
WE KNOW OF STEPHON HALPER
AND HIS CONTACT THAT HE MADE
WITH PAPADOPOULOS AND CARTER
PAGE AND SAM CLOVIS.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE FISA
WARRANT AS THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO SAID
THE BULK OF THE INFORMATION
IN THE APPLICATION WAS THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN OF ALL THINGS
DOSSIER, IGNORED BY THE
MUELLER REPORT WHICH I WILL
ASK YOU ABOUT IN A SECOND
HERE.
BUT THOSE ARE TWO SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS OF ATTEMPTS TO GET
INTO YOUR CAMPAIGN.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF
THAT.
>> WELL, I THINK THEY MADE
MANY ATTEMPTS.
AND THEN YOU SEE THE LYING
AND YOU SEE THE LEAKING AND
YOU SEE COMEY LIED CONGRESS.
NOTHING HAPPENED.
YOU SEE HIM LEAKING.
NOTHING HANS.
AND THIS IS LEAKING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THIS IS LEAKING REALLY BIG
STUFF.
I REMEMBER THE YOUNG SAILOR.
IN FACT, I HELPED HIM OUT
WITH HIS FAMILY BECAUSE HE
WAS SO UNFAIRLY TREATED AS
YOU KNOW.
I REMEMBER HE HAD
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
WHICH IS A MUCH, MUCH LOWER
STANDARD THAN CLASSIFIED.
AND THEY PUT HIM IN JAIL FOR
A LONG TIME.
THEY TOOK AWAY HIS LIFE.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON DID WITH
33,000 EMAILS AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF TEXT
MESSAGES OR EMAILS GOING
THROUGH THE WEINER SERVER OR
COMPUTER.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
WHICH MANY WERE CLASSIFIED.
AND NOTHING HAPPENS TO HER.
AND, YET, THEY PUT A YOUNG
SAILOR ON FOR DOING
SOMETHING INNOCENT, SHOWING
HIS MOTHER AND HIS FRIEND
WHAT THE DESK LOOKED LIKE.
THE DESK IN A 40-YEAR-OLD
SUBMARINE.
I THINK RUSSIA AND CHINA
WOULD HAVE HAD THAT PICTURE
MANY YEARS AGO.
SO IT'S REALLY A DOUBLE
STANDARD LIKE YOU'VE NEVER
SEEN, VERY, VERY UNFAIR.
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL CHANGE.
I THINK THAT WILL BE
CHANGING.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT,
CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY
RECENTLY REVEALED STRZOK AND
PAGE THAT THEY WERE LAUGHING
AT THE IDEA THAT HILLARY
INVESTIGATION WAS A REAL
INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT IT WENT DIRECTLY
INTO LORETTA LYNCH'S OFFICE,
WHICH NOW RAISES A WHOLE NEW
SET OF OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND THEY WERE CONFIDENT
ABOUT THAT.
AND IT WAS STRZOK THAT DID
THE INTERVIEW WITH HILLARY.
UNCHARACTERISTICALLY,
FRANKLY UNPRECEDENTED.
ALLOWED TWO OTHER PEOPLE IN
THAT INTERVIEW WHILE SHE WAS
BEING INTERVIEWED IN AN
INVESTIGATION.
COMEY, OF COURSE, EXONERATED
HER BUT HE EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED
TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON THAT SERVER.
DID I DISAGREE WITH YOU AT
THE TIME.
YOU AFTER THE ELECTION WERE
BASICALLY SAYING LET BY
GONES BE BY GONES LET'S NOT
GO DOWN THIS ROAD.
DO YOU REGRET SAYING THAT
AND DO YOU THINK NOW IF WE
ARE REALLY TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM AND THE TRUTH IT HAS
TO ALSO INCLUDE HILLARY
CLINTON, THE EMAIL SERVER.
WHICH WOULD BE AN UNDERLYING
CRIME AND OBSTRUCTION, WHICH
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA SEEMS
TO CARE ABOUT.
THE INTENT BEHIND THE 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS DELETED.
BLEACH BIT, HAMMERS, SIM
CARDS.
>> NO, I DON'T REGRET SAYING
IT.
WHEN I WON, THEY WERE ALL
SAYING LOCK HER UP.
LOCK HER UP.
I SAID NO, NO.
LET'S GET ON WITH LIFE.
THAT WAS DIFFERENT.
IT WAS LIKE RIGHT AFTER THE
ELECTION YOU WANT TO GET A
NEW PAGE AND TURN OVER A NEW
LEAF.
AND I SAID LET'S GET ON WITH
IT LET, YOU KNOW, BUILD UP
THE ECONOMY WHICH BY THE WAY
IS DOING RECORD BUSINESS.
I'M SO PROUD OF THE ECONOMY.
WE ARE DOING NUMBERS THAT
NOBODY HAS EVER BELIEVED.
PROBABLY THE BEST ECONOMY WE
HAVE EVER HAD.
BEST UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WE
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
BUT I SAID LET'S GET ON WITH
OUR LIFE.
LET'S FORGET ABOUT THE PAST.
BUT NOW WHAT HAPPENED IS
FAIRLY SHORTLY AFTER THAT
GREAT EVENING, THEY STARTED
COMING AT US WITH THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
AND EVERYTHING THEY DID WAS
SO DISHONEST.
AND THEN WE REALLY STARTED
LOOKING INTO A LOT OF THINGS
LIKE HER DELETED EMAILS AND
ACID WASHED EMAILS WHICH IS
UNHEARD OF BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE OF DOING IT.
AND HOW SHE GOT AWAY WITH
IT, HOW HER LAWYER GOT AWAY
WITH IT.
HOW ALL OF THESE THINGS
HAPPENED.
DON'T FORGET, WHETHER THEY
INTERVIEWED HER THAT WAS ON
JULY 4TH WEEKEND.
IT WAS VERY, VERY LATE INTO
THE JULY 4TH WEEKEND.
THEY ASKED HER QUESTIONS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
STENOGRAPHER.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY
SWEAR HER IN.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A TAPE
RECORDER.
THEY JUST WALKED IN, ASKED
HER SOME QUESTIONS.
AND THAT WAS FINE.
AND IN THE MEANTIME LOOK AT
WHAT SHE HAS DONE.
HOW SHE HAS GROID THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE ON OUR
CAMPAIGN SHE HAS DESTROYED
THEIR LIVES AND THE DNC.
AND FRANKLY WHEN THE FBI
WENT INTO THE DNC, THE DNC
TOLD THEM TO GET THE HELL
OUT OF HERE.
THINK OF THAT.
THEY TOLD THAT TO THE FBI
AND THEY WOULDN'T GIVE HIM
THE SERVER.
I WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT'S ON
THAT SERVER, THE DNC SERVER
THAT'S THE BIG THING NOBODY
HAS SEEN THAT SERVER YET.
THE FBI DIDN'T SEE IT THESE
ARE THE TOP PEOPLE AT THE
FBI WHERE YOU HAD ABSOLUTELY
DIRTY COPS.
THESE WERE DIRTY COPS.
NOW, THE FBI FBI GUYS THESE
ARE THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
COMEY AND McCABE AND
STRZOK AND PAGE AND ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE, THE LAWYER WHO
ADMITTED FRANKLY HOW CROOKED
THINGS WERE WHEN THAT
TESTIMONY COMES OUT IT'S
COME OUT PARTIALLY WHEN THAT
TESTIMONY COMBS
TESTIMONY COMES OUT THE
ATTORNEY FOR THE FBI YOU
WILL SEE.
NOW WE HAVE TO GET DOWN.
THIS WAS A COUP.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED
OVERTHROW OF THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT.
WE WILL PEOPLE COMING OUT TO
VOTE FROM ALL OVER THIS
COUNTRY THAT ARE IN LOVE
WITH WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IT'S CALLED MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND
WE ARE DOING.
THIS WAS AN OVERTHROW AND
IT'S A DISGRACEFUL THING.
I THINK IT'S FAR BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLY THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN POLITICAL
HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY.
MAYBE BEYOND POLITICAL SO I
THINK THAT A LOT OF THINGS
ARE BEING LEARNED RIGHT NOW
JUST LIKE YOU JUST MENTIONED
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
AGAIN WITH STRZOK AND PAGE.
THESE ARE SICK PEOPLE.
THESE ARE SICK, SICK PEOPLE.
SO LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH McCABE AND COMEY AND
BRENNAN AND CLAPPER.
THEY WEREN'T IN THE ACT.
AND LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS
AND LET'S SEE HOW HIGH IT
GOES UP.
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE WHEN IT
GOES TO CLAPPER, BRENNAN,
COMEY, THESE PEOPLE.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT SOME
OTHER PEOPLE MAY BE A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER UP ALSO KNEW
ABOUT IT AND MAYBE A LOT
HIGHER UP.
>> Sean: I MENTIONED NOW
STRZOK AND PAGE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
CONVERSATIONS.
PETER STRZOK HAD SAID ABOUT
THE COLLUSION THERE IS NO
THERE THERE.
LISA PAGE CLOSED DOOR
TESTIMONY ACTUALLY SAID
AFTER THE NINE MONTH FBI
INVESTIGATION THEY HAD NO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING WITH
YOU AND YOUR CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA.
THAT'S BEFORE THE
APPOINTMENT OF MUELLER.
WE ALSO HAD THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE REPORT.
THAT'S TWO.
NO COLLUSION, THEN THE
SENATE BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE
AND NOW THE MUELLER REPORT
IS YOU SAID ANY NEWS?
NO OBSTRUCTIONS.
NO COLLUSION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR FULL
REACTION TO THE MUELLER
REPORT?
>> WELL, IT WAS, AS I CALL
THEM, 13 ANGRY DEMOCRATS.
THEY WERE SUPPLANTED BY FIVE
MORE, FIVE MORE WERE ADDED.
AND YOU GOT UP TO 18, 19,
20.
THEY ARE ALL DEMOCRATS MANY
OF THEM MADE MAJOR
CONVICTIONS TO THE HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THEY
HAD ONE OF THEM WAS ONE OF
THE TOP PEOPLE AT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
JEANNE RAY.
YOU HAD WEISSMAN AND BAD,
BAD PEOPLE.
NO FRIENDS OF TRUMP.
I HAD NO FRIENDS.
IT WAS LIKE A ONE-SIDED
WITCH-HUNT AS I CALLED IT.
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUCH TOUGHER
WORD THAN THAT I WON'T USE
IT.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE THING.
HE WAS CONFLICTED FOR THAT
REASON.
HE ALSO WAS CONFLICTED
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
COMEY AND HIM ARE BEST
FRIENDS.
SO, IF NOT BEST, VERY CLOSE
TO BEST.
BUT I WOULD SAY BEST
FRIENDS.
YOU LOOK AT PICTURES OF THE
TWO OF THEM IN THE PAST.
WE HAD A NASTY BUSINESS
TRANSACTION THE TWO OF US.
I HAVE A NASTY TRANSACTION
WITH HIM AND THEN ALL OF THE
SUDDEN HE IS MY PROSECUTOR.
VERY, VERY UNFAIR WITH ALL
OF THAT AND $35 MILLION
SPENT.
THINK OF THAT OVER TWO YEARS
RUINING LIVES OF PEOPLE.
RUINING THEIR LIVES.
PEOPLE GOING OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T AFFORD
LAWYERS THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE
HOW T. BAD IT WAS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW BAD IT
WAS.
NOBODY KNOWS HOW PEOPLE
SUFFERED.
GREAT PEOPLE THAT CAME TO
WASHINGTON.
THEY CAME TO D.C. TO SET THE
WORLD IN A VERY POSITIVE WAY
ON FIRE THEY WANTED TO CLEAN
THINGS UP AND DO A GREAT
JOB.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE
TESTIFYING ON NONSENSE.
AND IT'S REALLY -- YOU KNOW,
WITH ALL OF THE THINGS
YOU'VE HEARD, NOTHING HAD TO
DO WITH THE CAMPAIGN.
NOTHING HAD TO DO WITH
RUSSIA, COLLUSION.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS A
GROUP OF VERY SERIOUS TRUMP
HATERS, A GROUP OF I CALL
THEM ANGRY DEMOCRATS.
SOMEBODY WHO WAS VERY
CONFLICTED AT THE TOP.
NO COLLUSION AND ALSO NO
OBSTRUCTION BECAUSE THE
STATEMENT WAS MADE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU KNOW,
UNDERSTOOD IT VERY WELL AND
HE READ IT AND HE MADE A
DECISION RIGHT ON THE SPOT.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
SO, YOU HAD NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
$35 MILLION SPENT.
AND UNLIMITED MANPOWER.
WOMAN POWER.
AND THERE IS NOTHING.
NOTHING AND IT WAS A VERY
BAD TWO YEARS FOR THIS
COUNTRY BURR WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WE FOUND EVERYTHING
GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
AND I THINK NOW IT'S TURNING
UNBELIEVABLE THE TABLES HAVE
TURNED AND YOU ARE SEEING
THINGS COME OUT LIKE YOU
JUST -- LIKE YOU JUST
NOTICED AND IT'S -- I THINK
IT'S GOINGS TO BE VERY
INTERESTING.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COUNTRY TO NOW FIND OUT HOW
THAT WHOLE THING STARTED.
AND IN ALL FAIRNESS TO BOB
MUELLER IT STARTED LONG
BEFORE HE WAS APPOINTED.
THIS WAS GOING ON LONG
BEFORE THAT.
YOU UNDERSTAND.
THE FIRST LADY AND I CAME
DOWN ON THE ESCALATOR ON
JUNE 16TH.
AND THIS STARTED VERY
SHORTLY AFTER THAT.
IT WAS A DISGRACE.
DISGRACE.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, WE
EXPECT A LOT MORE COMING OUT
IN THE DAYS, WEEKS, AND EVEN
MONTHS AHEAD.
WE KNOW AT LEAST 53 MORE
CLOSED DOOR -- THE TESTIMONY
CLOSED DOOR OF MANY OF THESE
PLAYERS THAT WILL BE
RELEASED.
WE KNOW THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL, HE NOW WILL HAVE
HIS REPORT.
WE EXPECT SOME TIME IN,
PERHAPS, IN MAY, LIKELY IN
MAY.
WHERE HE WILL -- HE HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING THE FISA ABUSE
ISSUE.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
HUBER ON LEAKING AND
WHATEVER HIS REPORT
ULTIMATELY ENDS UP BECOMING.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF INFORMATION AND THEN THE
ISSUE YOU HAVE THE LAST TIME
I TALKED TO YOU ABOUT A
MONTH AGO YOU SAID YOU WOULD
BE CLASSIFIED, THE FISA
APPLICATIONS, YOU WOULD
DECLASSIFY GANG OF 8
MATERIAL.
302 MATERIAL.
IF THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM-NUNEZ
MEMOS ARE CORRECT AND THE
BULK OF THE INFORMATION IN
THE FISA APPLICATIONS WERE
EVEN AS THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
SUGGESTED THIS WEEK, MAY
HAVE BEEN MISS INFORMATION
FROM THE RUSSIANS THAT
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR,
THAT WAS DES SEM NATEED TO
THE MEDIA AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BEFORE THAT ELECTION?
YOU KNOW, WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN FOR YOU.
>> FIRST OF ALL I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED THAT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" DID THAT THAT WALLS
THE VERY FIRST GLIMPSE THAT
MAYBE MAINSTREAM IS GOING TO
PICK UP THE GREATEST
POLITICAL SCANDAL IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
AGAIN, BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
BECAUSE IT MEANS SO MUCH
THIS WAS A COUP.
THIS WASN'T STEALING
INFORMATION FROM AN OFFICE
IN THE WATERGATE APARTMENTS.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED COUP.
IT'S UNCONCEIVABLE LIKE A
THIRD WORLD COUNTRY AND
INCONCEIVABLE.
AND I HAVE TO SAY I THINK
INFORMATION IS COMING OUT
AND IT'S COME OUT FAST.
MUCH FASTER THAN ANYBODY
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT:  THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON.
AND I WILL SAY THAT I.G.,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HOROWITZ, HE, OTHER THAN HIS
CONCLUSION, WHERE HE SAID NO
BIAS BUT HE MEANT THAT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN YOU WOULD
THINK.
HE GAVE A GREAT REPORT LAST
TIME.
AND I REALLY HOPE THAT HE IS
GOING TO GIVE -- HE WAS
APPOINTED BY OBAMA THAT
BOTHERS ME I CAN SEE IS HE
REALLY AN HONORABLE GUY.
I THINK HE KNOWS HOW BIG
THIS IS I THINK HE KNOWS HOW
BIG THIS IS AND IF HE IS AS
HONORABLE AS HE IS SUPPOSED
TO BE, THE IG REPORT COMING
OUT IN THREE OR FOUR WEEKS
FROM WHAT I HEAR IS GOING TO
BE AND SHOULD BE AND ALMOST
HAS TO BE A BLOCKBUSTER
BECAUSE HE HAS ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THAT MOST PEOPLE
DON'T.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE DID THE
LAST TIME HE WAS ABLE TO
FIND THINGS THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE, GREAT STUDENTS OF
THIS WHOLE THING LIKE DEVIN
NUNES WHO DESERVES A MEDAL
AND MEADOWS AND JIM JORDAN
ALL THESE GUYS, BIGGS.
AND YOU KNOW EVERY ONE OF
THEM THEY WORKED SO HARD.
THEY WORKED -- THEY COULDN'T
STAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
THE COUNTRY.
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT, HE DIDN'T
MENTION ANY OF THIS.
HE DIDN'T MENTION STRZOK
AND McCABE AND COMEY AND
THE LIES AND THE LEAKS AND
OVERTHROW AND THE WHOLE
THING WITH THE HILLARY
CLINTON GOT A WIN
100 MILLION TO 1 TWO LOVERS,
TWO SICK LOVERS, ESPECIALLY
THE ONE.
I MEAN, THESE WERE LIKE
CHILDREN AND THEY ARE FBI
PEOPLE.
THE TOP PEOPLE IN THE FBI.
I'M SO EMBARRASSED FOR THE
FBI WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
BUT THIS WAS.
HE DIDN'T MENTION THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
IT'S A VERY, VERY SAD THING.
IT CAN BE CLEARED UP
INCREDIBLY WELL.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW AND
SO I DO THAT WITHOUT -- IF
YOU DIDN'T GO ANY FURTHER
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
PROBLEMS.
I'M TRYING TO BE VERY NICE
AND I WANT TO BE VERY
TEMPERED BUT THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS PROBLEMS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
IF YOU HAD NO OTHER
INFORMATION, OTHER THAN WHAT
YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW,
TREMENDOUS PROBLEMS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
BUT, WHY DIDN'T THEY MENTION
IN THE MUELLER REPORT ALL OF
THE HORRIBLE THINGS THAT WE
FOUND OUT ABOUT THE OTHER
SIDE, INCLUDING THE FAKE
DOSSIER IN THE FAKE DOSSIER
WHICH EVEN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" NOW SAYS WAS FAKE,
WHICH, AGAIN, I RESPECT THAT
THEY CAME OUT AND SAID IT
THIS IS TOO BIG A DEAL FOR
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO GIVE UP.
BUT THE NICE PART IS, AS FAR
AS TRUMP IS CONCERNED AND
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THERE
IS NO COLLUSION AND THERE IS
NO OBSTRUCTION.
NOW IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, IF,
IN FACT, THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" IS RIGHT AND THE
DOSSIER WAS A DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN BY RUSSIA.
THAT WOULD MEAN AS BRUCE OHR
TESTIFIED BEHIND CLOSE THE
DOORS THAT HE EVEN TOLD --
AND BY THE WAVY AGREE WITH
YOU ABOUT THE FBI, 99% ARE
GOOD PEOPLE.
THIS IS ONLY A FEW AT THE
TOP IF THEY USED THAT
DOSSIER AS THE BULK OF
INFORMATION AND IT'S
DISINFORMATION TO USE THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" WORDS FROM
RUSSIA THAT HILLARY CLINTON,
OF THE OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE PAID FOR THAT THEY
NEVER FULLY INFORMED THE
FISA JUDGES OF AND THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO, NUNES
MEMO WAS RIGHT.
THAT MEANS THAT EVERYBODY
SIGNED OFF ON THOSE FOUR
FISA APPLICATIONS THAT WOULD
BE THE FIRST ONE JIM COMEY.
THAT WOULD BE SALLY YATES,
ROD ROSENSTEIN, THAT MEANS
THEY NEVER VERIFIED WHAT
THEY TOLD THAT COURT.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S A FRAUD
ON THE FISA COURT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> WELL FROM, WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THEY WOULD ALL BE
IN A VERY BIG PILE OF
TROUBLE.
THAT'S THE WAY I LOOK AT IT
AND THAT'S THE WAY I HEAR.
THEY WOULD BE IN A VERY BIG
AMOUNT OF TROUBLE.
IT WOULD BE A TERRIBLE THING
IF THAT'S THE CASE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DENYING THAT.
AND THEY STARTED BLAMING ALL
SORTS OF PEOPLE,
PAPADOPOULOS WHO NOBODY KNEW
AND CARTER PAGE OHIO
ACTUALLY FEEL VERY SORRY
FOR.
I NEVER MET THEM.
THEY USED HIM TO TRY AND SPY
ON THE CAMPAIGN.
YOU KNOW, THEY WENT IN AND
THESE TWO GUYS WERE PUT ON
COUNCILS HAVING TO DO WITH
VARIOUS THINGS.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT
MAKE?
THEY WERE PUT ON TO FOREIGN
RELATIONS COUNCILS AND WITH
A LARGE NUMBER OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
AS SOON AS PEOPLE SAW THEIR
NAME -- EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T
MEET CARTER PAGE AND
PAPADOPOULOS I ACTUALLY SAT
AT A TABLE WITH HIM FOR
ABOUT 15 MINUTES AND THAT
WAS IT.
I NEVER SPOKE TO HIM OR
ANYTHING.
AND THEY WERE -- YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE SUFFERED A LOT.
I DON'T SEE THAT THEY WERE
NOT FOOLISH BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THE TWAY ALL HAPPENED
WAS SO CRAZY.
BUT THEY WERE HIT LIKE VERY
FEW PEOPLE HAVE EVER BEEN
HIT.
THAT WAS REALLY TO GET TO
ME.
THAT WAS TO GET TO THE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY STARTED USING THEM IN
ORDER TO SPY ON OUR
CAMPAIGN.
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE, I MEAN,
AGAIN, IT WILL COME OUT AT
SOME POINT SO I DON'T WANT
TO BE THE ONE TO SAY.
BUT TO ME IT SEEMS TO BE
PRETTY OBVIOUS WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED WITH CARTER
PAGE AND IT'S -- THEY WERE
SPYING, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAID IT BETTER THAN ANYBODY
THE OTHER DAY WHEN HE WAS
ASKED YES, I THINK THEY WERE
SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
YOU CAN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER
THAN THAT.
AND I THINK SO, TOO.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
NEW GREEN DEAL BIDEN AND THE
MEDIA.
ONE LAST, LAST QUESTION.
WILL YOU DECLASSIFY THE FISA
APPLICATIONS, GANG OF 8
MATERIAL, THOSE 302s OR,
YOU KNOW, WHAT WE CALL ON
THIS PROGRAM THE BUCKET OF
FIVE?
>> YES.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE
DECLASSIFIED AND MORE, MUCH
MORE THAN WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
IT WILL ALL BE DECLASSIFIED.
I'M GLAD I WAITED BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT MAYBE THEY
WOULD OBJECT STRUCTURE IF I
DID IT EARLY AND I THINK I
WAS RIGHT.
SO I'M GLAD I WAITED.
NOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
TAKE A VERY STRONG LOOK AT
WHATEVER IT IS.
IT WILL BE DECLASSIFIED AND
MORE THAN WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, WE
ARE NOW IN THE ELECTION
SEASON AND JOE BIDEN MADE
HIS BIG ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A VERY WARM
WELCOME YOU MADE FOR HIM ON
TWITTER WHICH I READ AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW MERE
TONIGHT.
GENERALLY YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HIM, HIS ENTRY INTO THE RACE
RACE; YOU HAVE BERNIE
SANDERS ELIZABETH WARREN,
ROBERT FRANCIS O'ROURKE,
YOUR REACTION TO WELL NOW A
RECORD NUMBER OF SLATE OF 20
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE YOU ON IN 2020?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHO IT
IS GOING TO BE.
MAYBE SANDERS OR MAYBE
BIDEN.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT JOE, I HAVE KNOWN
JOE OVER THE YEARS.
HE IS NOT THE BRIGHTEST
LIGHT BULB IN THE GROUP, I
DON'T THINK SO, BUT HE HAS A
NAME THAT THEY KNOW.
HE IS COMING ON WITH A
LITTLE CUTE STATEMENTS ABOUT
ME THAT HE TALKED ABOUT THE
WAY THE WORLD IS TODAY.
WELL, I WILL TELL YOU THE
WAY THE WORLD IS TODAY IS WE
HAVE A STRONG MILITARY.
WE HAVE CHOICE FOR OUR
VETERANS.
THEY HAVE CHOICE NOW INSTEAD
OF WAITING IN LINE ALL DAY
LONG, ALL WEEK LONG, ALL
MONTH LONG.
THEY HAVE CHOICE.
THEY CAN GO OUT TO A PRIVATE
DOCTOR.
WE PAY THE BILL AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DIE WAITING IN
LINE.
WE HAVE THE BIGGEST TAX CUT
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE GOTTEN RID OF THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
WE HAVE HAD THE BIGGEST CUT
IN REGULATIONS WHICH IS ONE
OF THE THINGS CREATING ALL
THESE GREAT JOBS BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE BEST UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS WE HAVE EVER HAD.
TODAY WE HAVE THE MOST
PEOPLE WORKING LITERALLY
TODAY, JUST CAME OUT.
WE HAVE THE MOST PEOPLE
WORKING THAN WE HAVE EVER
HAD IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
ALMOST 160 MILLION PEOPLE
ARE WORKING TO HAVE JOBS.
AND IT'S INCREDIBLE.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S REALLY
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WE REBUILT THE MILITARY.
WE HAVE ORDERED JETS, THE
LIKES OF WHICH NO COUNTRY
HAS.
WE HAVE FIGHTER JETS.
THE F I 35.
THE F-18.
WE HAVE JETS THE LIKES WHICH
NO COUNTRY HAS AT ALL.
WE ARE ORDERING GREAT, GREAT
SHIPS, BOATS, AIRCRAFT
CARRIERS AND THEY ARE ALL
BEING BUILT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT'S JOBS.
IT'S ALL BEING BUILT RIGHT
HERE.
BEST EQUIPMENT IN THE WORLD.
BEST MISSILES IN THE WORLD.
WEASEL DON'T WANT TO USE
THEM BUT IF WEE HAVE TO, WE
ARE SET.
NOBODY HAS WHAT WE HAVE.
NOBODY HAS OUR MILITARY.
NOBLE IS EVEN CLOSE.
WHEN I CAME, IN WE HAD A
DEPLETED MILITARY.
WE HAD AN ECONOMY THAT WAS
GOING DOWN.
YOU REMEMBER THE NUMBERS.
THEY WERE TERRIBLE.
AND THEY WERE GOING DOWN.
WE WERE GOING TO BE IN
NEGATIVE NUMBERS VERY SOON
AND NOW WE HAVE NUMBERS THAT
ARE INCREDIBLE.
THE ECONOMY IS SETTING
RECORDS.
WHEN FOREIGN LEADERS COME IN
TO SEE ME, SEAN, THEY ALWAYS
SAY THANK YOU, IT'S GREAT TO
MEET YOU, SIR.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
ECONOMY.
IT'S THE GREATEST ECONOMY
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD WHICH
IT IS.
NOBODY IS EVEN CLOSE TO US.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE BEEN DONE.
WHEN BIDEN MAKES THE
STATEMENT TALKING ABOUT THE
SOUL, I MEAN THE SOUL, TAKE
A LOOK AT THE OBAMA I HEARD
SOMEBODY SAY BEFORE THAT
THERE WAS SUCH DISSENSION
AND DIVISION.
PEOPLE FORGET THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS DIVISION DURING
OUT OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
TREMENDOUS DIVISION.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE GREAT
SPIRIT RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, JUST TO FINISH
THAT OFF.
WE ARE A COUNTRY RESPECTED
AGAIN.
WE ARE RESPECTED ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
THEY ALL RESPECT US EVEN
TODAY I SEE WHERE PRESIDENT
PUTIN IN RUSSIA MADE THE
STATEMENT THAT IT'S GREAT TO
BE ABLE TO HELP US WITH KIM
JONG UN AND NORTH KOREA.
WE WANT TO GET RID OF THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE ALL HAVE TO GET -- RUSSIA
HAS TO GET RID OF THEM AND
CHINA HAS TO GET RID OF
THEM.
BY THE WAY CHINA, PRESIDENT
XI HAS BEEN A BIG HELP.
WE ARE WORKING ON A GREAT
TRAILED DEAL.
HE HAS BEEN A GREAT HELP AT
THE BORDER I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE BORDER BETWEEN NORTH
KOREA AND CHINA.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
WE ARE RESPECTED AGAIN
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THAT'S A GREAT THING.
>> Sean: WELL, IN BIDEN'S
CASE IN PARTICULAR, HE IS
GOING TO RUN ON HIS ECONOMIC
RECORD VERSUS YOURS.
HIS POSITION ON IRAN AND
ISRAEL AND NORTH KOREA VS.
YOURS.
BUT, GENERALLY SPEAKING, WE
HAVE NOT JUST CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ ABOUT 100
HOUSE, SENATE MEMBERS AT
LEAST AND MANY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES FOR 2020 HAVE
BOUGHT INTO THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
EVERYTHING IS FREE.
NO OIL, NO GAS.
COMRADE GLAZA HAS
COMRADE DLAZA HAS
COMRADE DE ZA HAS
COMRADE DE BL HAS
COMRADE DE BLASAS
COMRADE DE BLASIO HAS ADDED
NO STEEL BUILDING OR GLASS
BUILDINGS.
PLANE ENGINES COMBUSTION
ENGINES ARE GONE.
HOW DO YOU REACT IF THESE
ARE THE POLICIES YOU WILL BE
RUNNING AGAINST?
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
I JUST HEARD ABOUT THIS
CRAZY DEAL IN NEW YORK CITY
WHERE THEY WANT TO BUILD
CONCRETE BUILDINGS THAT
LITTLE TINY WINDOWS.
I 3WEU89 A LOT OF BUILDINGS,
SEAN, I CAN TELL YOU THE
BIGGER THE WINDOW THE BETTER
I DID WITH IT.
BEAM WANT BIG WINDOWS AND
NOW THEY WILL TAKE THEM DOWN
TO NOTHING.
THE WHOLE THING IS CRAZY.
THE NEW GREEN NEW DEAL,
OKAY, AND IT'S GOT TO BE
SOME KIND OF A JOKE.
IT'S GOT TO BE -- THEY HAVE
TO BE KIDDING BUT, YOU KNOW,
I SAW THE SENATOR FROM
HAWAII WHO WAS SO NASTY TO
JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND THAT'S
ANOTHER THING, WE'LL SOON
HAVE WITHIN A PERIOD YOU
HAVE ABOUT TWO MONTHS 145
BRAND NEW FEDERAL JUDGES AND
TWO SUPREME COURT JUDGES.
BUT SHE WAS SO NASTY TO NOW
JUDGE JUSTICE KAVANAUGH SO
HORRIBLE.
THEY ASKED HER ABOUT IT.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEY SAID HOW ABOUT THAT?
AND SHE GHOST WELL, I'M IN
HAWAII AND I UNDERSTAND THEY
WON'T ALLOW AIRPLANES AND
SHE SAID IT'S HARD FOR ME
BUT I WILL APPROVE IT
ANYWAY.
EVEN THOUGH THERE IS NO WAY.
SOMEBODY SAID THEY WILL
BUILD A TRAIN TO HAWAII.
NO, IT'S A CRAZY THING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY ARE
REALLY SERIOUS.
BUT I HOPE THEY GET A CHANCE
TO RUN AGAINST IT.
I HOPE THEY DON'T
DISSEMINATE IT.
SOMETIMES I ALMOST WISH I
DIDN'T SAY AS MUCH AS I HAVE
SAID TO YOU ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE I WANT THAT TO GO
THROUGH AND I WANT TO RUN
AGAINST IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE GOING
TO WIN ANYWAY BUT SURE AS
HELL NOT GOING TO WIN WITH
THAT LEGISLATION.
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN ANYWAY
FROM A PRACTICAL STANDPOINT,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THE
SENATORS.
SENATORS THAT I HAVE KNOWN
FOR A LONG TIME
DISTINGUISHED DEMOCRATS AND
THEY ARE FAWNING BEHIND HER.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
DEAL U I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
ARE KIDDING.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE
DESPERATE FOR VOTES OR I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE
INCOMPETENT, BUT THEY ARE
SITTING BEHIND HER AND THEY
ARE ACTING LIKE THEY
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH WHAT SHE
IS SAYING ABOUT FUEL OIL AND
COWS AND ALL OF THE THINGS.
I MEAN, IT'S RIDICULOUS
SITUATION.
SO I JUST HOPE IT KEEPS
GOING.
I HOPE NOBODY CRITICIZES IT
TOO BADLY.
I HAVE ALREADY DONE TOO MUCH
TONIGHT.
MAYBE I WOULD HAVE TALKED
THEM OUT OF IT AND THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A VERY BAD
THING.
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO IT.
WE HAD AN INCIDENT THIS
BOOK.
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE OF
THE BORDER.
OBVIOUSLY A DEFINING ISSUE
FOR YOU.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: CONGRESS WAS UNABLE
TO OVERRIDE YOUR EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
THE PENTAGON HAS ICHED, I
BELIEVE THE FIGURE WAS
$9 BILLION OF UNUSED MONEY
AND YOU WERE GOING TO APPLY
THAT TO THE WALL.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THEN WE HAD THE
INCIDENT THIS WEEK WHERE WE
HAD SOME PEOPLE CROSS OUR
BORDER AND LITERALLY, YOU
KNOW, TOOK ONE OF OUR GUYS'
GUNS.
YOU PUT OUT A TWEET BETTER
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
WHAT'S THE LATEST WITH BOTH
THE WALL.
WHAT'S THE LATEST ON THAT
SITUATION AND WHAT IS -- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD
ABOUT THIS CONTRACTOR THAT
SAID HE CAN BUILD A WHOLE
WALL FOR A LOT CHEAPER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE AND GET IT DONE
BY 2020.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
>> YES, WE ARE DEALING WITH
HIM, ACTUALLY.
IT'S FISHER COMES FROM NORTH
DAKOTA.
RECOMMENDED STRONGLY BY A
GREAT NEW SENATOR AS YOU
KNOW, KEVIN CRAMER.
AND THEY ARE REAL.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN BIDDING
AND SO FAR THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
MEETING THE BIDS.
I THOUGHT THEY WOULD.
WE ARE BUILDING MANY
SECTIONS OF WALL RIGHT NOW
THAT'S UNDER CONSTRUCTION
RIGHT NOW.
AND I INTEND TO HAVE BY THE
END OF NEXT YEAR OVER
400 MILES OF WALL WHICH
RENOVATED A LOT OF WALL
ALREADY.
A LOT OF THE WALL WAS, YOU
KNOW, I'M GOOD AT THIS
STUFF.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
WE RENOVATED A LOT.
WE HAD WALL THAT WAS FALLING
DOWN BUT STRUCTURALLY STRONG
OR CAN BE STRONG.
SO WE SAVED A LOT OF MONEY.
WE RENOVATED.
WE FIXED IT AND IT'S MUCH
QUICKER AND FRANKLY MUCH
LESS EXPENSIVE.
SO WE HAVE RENOVATED A LOT
AND WE BUILT A LOT.
WE BUILT A LOT OF NEW WALL
IN SOME CASES.
WE HAVE RIPPED ALL WALL DOWN
BECAUSE IT WAS IN TOO BAD OF
SHAPE AND WE BUILT NEW WALL.
WE ARE BUILDING A LOT OF
SECTIONS AND ACTUALLY OVER
THE NEXT TWO TO THREE WEEKS
WE ARE GIVING OUT AT LOVE
SECTIONS.
THEY WILL BE BUILDING IT IN
DIFFERENT AREAS BY DIFFERENT
CONTRACTORS A SIMILAR DESIGN
AND A REALLY GOOD DESIGN.
LESS MONEY.
MORE BEAUTIFUL AND ACTUALLY
STRONGER.
>> Sean: "THE WASHINGTON
TIMES," LET ME GO TO THE
ISSUE OF MEDIA AND -- I'M
SORRY "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES" RECEIVED
PLUSSERS
PUUSSERS
PULISERS
PULITZRS
PULITZER FOR THEIR QUOTE HE
COVERAGE OF THE RUSSIAN
PROBE.
YOU'VE SEEN THE COVERAGE
OVER 2 PLUS YEARS.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
TRUMP, TRUMP, TRUMP.
COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
THE MUELLER REPORT COULDN'T
BE ANY MORE CLEAR ON THE
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY.
DO YOU THINK THE NEWS MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEIR
COVERAGE ON THIS OWES YOU AN
APOLOGY?
>> WELL, THEY DO OWE ME AN
APOLOGY.
A BIG ONE.
THEY OWE YOU AN APOLOGY AND
ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY AND
SOMEBODY OF THE OTHER.
>> Sean: I'M THOUGHT HOLDING
MY BREATH.
>> WE ACTUALLY HAD A LOT OF
SUPPORT.
I WATCH YOU AND TUCKER AND I
WATCH LAURA AND YOUR GREAT
GUYS IN THE MORNING WITH
STEVE AND AINSLEY AND BRIAN.
BRIAN CAME A LONG WAY.
I KID HIM BUT HE CAME A LONG
WAY.
AND SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY ON FOX, IN ALL FAIR
NEWS.
BUT YOU LOOK AT JESSE HAS
BEEN SO GREAT.
JUST SO MANY PEOPLE WE HAD A
LOT OF SUPPORT.
INCLUDING AS YOU WOULD SAY
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES" AND
SOME OTHERS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING, IT'S
CORRUPT REPORTING.
GENERALLY SPEAKING IT WAS
FAKE NEWS.
AND A TERM THAT, YOU KNOW,
I'M VERY PROUD OF SOMEBODY
SAID WHICH IS THE BEST OF
THE NAMES, MAYBE MAKE
THE NAMES, MAYBE FAKE NEWS.
THEY USE IT TO DESCRIBE
SOMETHING.
THEY THINK THEY GET OUT OF
IT BY USE IT.
THEY ARE TRICKY PEOPLE.
THEY WERE FAKE AND CORRUPT.
IF THEY COULD CHANGE I WOULD
BE THE FIRST ONE TO SAY I
RESPECT THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE CHANGED.
IF THEY DON'T CHANGE, THEY
HAVE LOST ALL CREDIBILITY.
IF YOU READ THE STORIES THAT
THEY WROTE ABOUT THE RUSSIA
WITCH-HUNT AND BY THE WAY,
GUYS LIKE DAN BONGINO AND
GREGG JARRETT AND JUSTICE
JEANINE, HOW ABOUT JUDGE
JEANINE WHOSE MOTHER JUST
DIED TODAY WHICH IS
HORRIBLE.
I JUST SPOKE TO HER.
SHE IS A GREAT WOMAN.
LOVED HER MOTHER MORE THAN
ANYBODY OTHER THAN HER
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN.
BUT I MEAN, SHE LOVED HER
MOTHER.
SHE WAS A GREAT DAUGHTER.
SHE HAS GONE THROUGH A HARD
TIME.
BUT HOW ABOUT JEANINE AND I
MEAN IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
WE HAVE FAR MORE SUPPORT
THAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
IF WE DIDN'T, I WOULDN'T
EVEN BE TALKING TO YOU RIGHT
NOW.
IT WOULD BE A TOTAL MESS.
WE HAD ENOUGH TO FIGHT THE
DEEP STATE.
WE HAD ENOUGH TO FIGHT
CORRUPT MEDIA, MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, I MINE, NBC, I THINK
WAS WORST.
I THINK NBC IS MORE CORRUPT
THAN CNN IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
I MADE THEM A LOT OF MONEY
WITH THE APPRENTICE.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
DID I THAT THING 12 YEARS
WITH THE APPRENTICE.
THEY WANTED TO SIGN ME THREE
OR FOUR MORE YEARS.
THEY CAME UP TO MY OFFICE I
SAID I'M RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THEY'VE TRIED TO TALK ME OUT
OF IT I FIGURED AT LEAST
THEY WOULD GIVE ME FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEY WOULD
GIVE ME GREAT.
I HAVE THINK THEY WERE MORE
HOSTILE FRANKLY THAN CNN
WHICH IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
BUT THIS FAKE FAKE, HORRIBLE
STUFF, NOBODY CAN BELIEVE
HOW DISHONEST THEY HAVE
BEEN.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT I
HAVE KNOWN YOU PERSONALLY
FOR WELL OVER TWO DECADES.
AND BY THE WAY I DON'T THINK
THE FAKE NEWS BRAND IS GOING
AWAY, BUT ON ALL THE ISSUES
YOU RAN ON, CONSERVATIVE,
ORIGINALIST, CONSTITUTIONAL
JUSTICES, TAX CUTS,
DEREGULATION, ISRAEL.
IRAN, FOREIGN POLICY.
THE WALL.
WE'RE NOW ENERGY INDEPENDENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN I
THINK 70, 75 YEARS.
WE ARE NOW A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
THE ONE THING REPUBLICANS,
YOU'VE GOTTEN PART OF IT
DONE.
WAS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU WANT TO TAKE ON
HEALTHCARE AND MITCH
MCCONNELL SAID NOT THIS
YEAR.
>> HE IS GOING TO BE GREAT.
MITCH IS DOING A VERY GOOD
JOB.
HE HAS A PASSION FOR THE
COURTS, GOUT A PASSION FOR
JUDGES.
WE HAVE WORKED GREAT ON
THAT.
WE WILL BE REALLY GOOD WITH
HEALTHCARE.
WE WANT TO HAVE -- WE ARE
GOING TO DO THINGS THAT
NOBODY HAS EVER SEEN ON
HEALTHCARE.
BUT WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
THE HOUSE.
AND IN ORDER TO DO IT WE
HAVE TO TAKE BACK THE HOUSE.
IF WE DON'T TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE, THEN WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO HAVE
GOOD HEALTHCARE.
OBAMACARE IS A DISASTER.
TOO EXPENSIVE, NOT WORKING.
WE HAD IT DONE.
IT WAS DONE AND THEN JOHN
MCCAIN AT THE VERY LAST
MOMENT LATE IN THE EVENING
WENT THUMBS DOWN AND
EVERYBODY SAID WHAT WAS
THAT?
JOHN MCCAIN WENT THUMBS
DOWN.
HE DID THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
A TREMENDOUS DISSERVICE AND
DID THE NATION A TREMENDOUS
DISSERVICE.
TREMENDOUS.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT WE
HAD IT DONE.
AS H. WE KNOW -- BECAUSE HE
SAID HE WAS VOTING FOR IT
ALL DAY LONG.
HAD WE KNOWN HE WAS GOING TO
GO AGAINST I THINK WE COULD
HAVE COMBINED ONE OF THE
OTHER TWO PEOPLE.
MIGHT MEAL COMFORT TO GO FOR
A BOYD.
WE KNEW WE HAD JOHN MCCAIN
AND ALL SET.
HE WENT THUMBS DOWN AT THE
VERY LAST MOMENT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A
DISGRACEFUL THING TO DO AND
VERY, VERY BAD FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND BAD FOR
HEALTHCARE.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
GREAT.
WE HAVE TO GET THE HOUSE
BACK.
IT WILL BE MUCH BETTER THAN
OBAMACARE.
AND DON'T FORGET, THEY WANT
TO TAKE 180 MILLION PRIVATE
INSURANCE PLANS AWAY.
PEOPLE, 180 MILLION PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE STRIPPED OF
THEIR GREAT INSURANCE THAT
THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE MADE GREAT INSURANCE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE.
OBAMACARE IS ACTUALLY, IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY A SMART
PART.
WE HAVE A VERY BIG CASE IN
COURT.
I THINK EVENTUALLY THE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WOULD COME TOGETHER.
BUT WE HAVE A FANTASTIC PLAN
THAT WE'LL BE ROLLING OUT
AND SUBJECT TO US WINNING
BACK THE HOUSE, KEEPING THE
PRESIDENCY, WHICH I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
AND ALSO OBVIOUSLY WINS THE
SENATE.
AND AS YOU KNOW, IN '18 WE
PICKED UP SEATS IN THE
SENATE BUT NOBODY EVER GIVES
US CREDIT FOR THAT WE WON
THE GOVERNORSHIPS OF MANY
STATES, INCLUDING OHIO AND
GEORGIA AND FLORIDA AND WE
HAD, YOU KNOW, JUST GREAT.
WE WERE AT 53 TO 47.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THAT WE
HAD ACTUALLY A VERY
SUCCESSFUL -- WE REALLY DID.
WE HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL 18
ELECTION AND DON'T FORGET
THE SENATE THAT APPROVES THE
JUDGES NOMINEES.
MOST IMPORTANTLY PERHAPS THE
JUDGES.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, IN THIS
WHOLE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS
YOU NEVER INVOKED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
YOU HANDED OVER EVERY
DOCUMENT.
YOU TOLD YOUR STAFF TO
COOPERATE, THAT'S FAIRLY
UNPRECEDENT YOU HAD.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT YOU
SAID IT WAS A WITCH LUNT.
INNOCENT NO COLLUSION THE
ENTIRE TIME.
WHY DON'T WE FIRE MUELLEROR
ROSEN SIGN WHATEVER HAPPENED
TO BE.
YOU HAD THE AUTHORITY UNDER
DERSHOWITZ AND OTHERS YOU
NEVER ABOUT THOSE THING TO
WHEN YOU SAID THIS WEEK YOU
WILL I WILL FIGHT ALL
SUBPOENAS AND ENOUGH
COOPERATING.
CAN YOU EXPAND ON WHAT YOU
MEANT AND WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> VERY SIMPLY ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
I COULD HAVE FIRED
EVERYBODY.
BUT.
>> I WANTED TO YOU HAVE
TRANSPARENCY.
ARTICLE 2.
I COULD HAVE FIRED MUELLER.
I YOU COULD HAVE FIRED
ANYBODY I WANTED TO FIRE
ARTICLE 2.
I FIRED NOBODY OTHER THAN
COMEY AND THE HAVE
INTERESTING AND THAT WAS
EARLY AND PEOPLE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT, BUT THE VERY
INTERESTING THING ABOUT
FIRING COMEY IS THAT
EVERYBODY WANTED HIM FIRED.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS.
I MEAN, VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY.
THE DEMOCRATS THOUGHT HE WAS
HORRIBLE.
THE REPUBLICANS THOUGHT HE
WAS OWNER.
AND I SAID, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS GOING TO BE WONDERFUL.
I'M GOING TO FIRE THIS GUY.
WHEN HE GETS FIRED I THOUGHT
IT WAS GO GOING TO BE
POPULAR.
ENED HE GOT FIRED AND THE
DEMOCRATS SATBACK AND THEY
THOUGHT AND THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT TWO DAYS EARLIER SAYING
HOW HORRIBLE HE WAS SAYING
THIS IS A TERRIBLE THICK.
WHAT'S A TERRIBLE THING IS
THEY ARE NOT PUTTING OUR
COUNTRY FIRST.
I HAVE BEEN THE MOST
TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
I SAID LET ANYBODY SPEAK.
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL CAN
SPEAK.
I HEARD, I MEAN THIS IS
INCREDIBLE.
I HEARD THEY INTERVIEWED 500
PEOPLE I DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD
THAT MANY PEOPLE BETWEEN THE
HOUSE AND OTHER BRANCHES.
I MEAN, WHO WOULD THINK THEY
INTERVIEWED 500 PEOPLE IF
THAT IS POSSIBLE TO BE
CORRECT.
THEY SPENT, AS I TOLD YOU,
$35 MILLION.
THEY HAD UNLIMITED HUMAN
RESOURCES.
THEY HAD THE FBI WORKING FOR
THEM.
THEY HAD U.S. ATTORNEYS.
THEY HAD THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WORKING FOR THEM.
AND THEY FOUND NO COLLUSION.
BUT I WAS TOTALLY
TRANSPARENT.
I DIDN'T TELL ANYBODY YOU
CAN'T GO.
I COULD HAVE.
I COULD HAVE SELL YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO TESTIFY.
>> WHEN I SAY IT THEY DO
WHAT I SAY.
I COULD HAVE SAID THAT WHAT
HAPPENED SEAN I WANTED TO BE
TOTALLY TRANSPARENTS THEN WE
GET NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTIONS.
THEN THE HOUSE GOES.
I SAID WE HAVE HAD IT.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, ONLY
FOR THE CONSTRAINTS OF TIME,
I WOULD LOVE TO ASK YOU IN
DETAIL ABOUT ALL THESE
CANDIDATES.
HOW ABOUT ONE WORD
DESCRIPTION ON SOME OF THE
TOP CAP DEMOCRATS FOR 2020
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, IF I SAY
THE WORD JOE BIDEN ONE OR
TWO WORDS?
>> I THINK WE ARE CALLING
HIM SLEEPY JOE.
I HAVE KNOWN HIM FOR A WHILE
IS HE A PRETTY SLEEPY GUY.
HE WON'T BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH PRESIDENT XI.
I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
ENERGY AND, FRANKLY,
INTELLIGENCE.
SOLVE THOUGHT REFER TO HIM
AS SLEEPY JOB A LOT OF
PEOPLE WANTED ME TO TAKE THE
WORD SLEEPY WITH SOMETHING
THAT RHYMES WITH IT.
>> YES.
>> HE IS NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE JOB.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT BERNIE
SANDERS?
>> WELL, HE HAS A LOT OF
ENERGY BUT HE HAS GOT
MISGUIDED ENERGY AND DONE
VERY POORLY IN TERMS OF THE
SENATE.
HE HAS HAD VERY LITTLE
LEGISLATION.
I THINK HE TALKS A LOT.
DOES HE GET IT DONE?
>> Sean: ROBERT FRANCIS
O'ROURKE?
>> WELL, IT'S A FLUKE.
TED CRUZ DID A GOOD JOB.
I HELPED HIM A LOT IN TEXAS.
WE WENT DOWN AND HAD A
COUPLE OF MASSIVE RALLIES.
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS ARE
INCREDIBLE.
THEY FIGURED IT ALL OUT.
HE IS FADING VERY FAST, HE
IS FADING VERY, VERY FAST.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE WILL BE A
THING OF THE PAST VERY SOON.
HE WAS A HOT ITEM.
THEE YOU HOW DISHONEST THE
PRESS WAS.
I HAVE WENDT DOWN TO EL
PASO, WE HAD D. THIS
TREMENDOUS RALLY AT LEAST
500 PEOPLE.
THE PRESS SAID THEY BOTH HAD
BIG RALLIES ONE BECAUSE HAD
0,000 AND ONE HAS 100.
THEY WERE VERY MUCH
COMPARING THEM.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
UFT.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT'S
THOUGHT FREE BUT THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: WE HAVE LESS THAN A
MINUTE LEFT.
MAYOR PETE, KAMALA HARRIS.
>> WELL, I DON'T SEE EITHER
OF THEM.
I THINK SHE HAS GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF A NASTY WHIT BUT THAT
MIGHT BE IT AND MAYOR PETE
IS NOT GOING TO MAKE IT I
WOULD HOPE HE WOULD.
I'M ROUTING FOR HIM BUT HE
IS NOT GOING TO MAKE IT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE BEEN
VERY YEN GENEROUS, ONCE
AGAIN, WITH YOUR TIME.
I HAVE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT,
SOMETIMES I KNOW WHEN YOU DO
OTHER INTERVIEWS THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO PLAY GOTCHA FIGHTING
MAD THEIR OWN AGENDA.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO HEAR YOU
IN ANSWER IN YOUR OWN WORDS
AT LENGTH ON SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
WE DO APPRECIATE YOU COMING